okay next game what does some big-ass
international master from latvia and i
played him a lot of times and lost a lot
of times so let's see what we get this
time got the catalan and yeah this is
all a well-known line let's see if we
can get something on out of this
position it is fairly solid for black of
course
if you wonder why I play this moves so
quickly um it's not the first time that
I had this against him
so as sick as it may sound this is sound
really opening preparation okay
let's try if I can get something with
Bishop g7 on b2 I a to this position
known already should be young at least
equal for black but you need to be very
cautious against him because um he's a
very good end game player and also um
it's notorious for simply playing on
completely dead positions rook worthless
rock and and similar stuff okay I'm what
if I just play rook c8 what what does he
do then take it peanuts retreat yeah and
it sounds a dead wrong check
ok let's let's be exact here
nevertheless play Bishop to g7 yet
cannot bet ok
ok this poll
what about a five and let's try play
five okay
every trip now here idea being 94
okay let's just bring the king in hmm I
didn't play this really good he can can
now try to get something with some night
to be seven
yeah it's not overly overly dramatic but
until I should have avoided this can i
activate somehow yeah this night is
really a silly piece I don't really have
a good move here in this I didn't see
one let's just try to to wait till it
takes it doesn't take
can try to get the bishop over here to
to win pawns
yeah i'm also down two minutes this this
will most likely get lost if not on
position then on time yeah completely
unnecessary of course this was just that
wrong time warning but of course i made
an awful move with them a five
completely unnecessary
still not not f7 yeah no time and yeah
okay black resides yeah this was of
course completely unnecessary to
completely drawn position what what what
should I play to to make to not get into
any of any problems here of course I'm
with this extended pawns I need to be a
bit cautious but it should be easy so
what could be a good idea here
just to avoid any problems
yeah maybe I should just just keep them
to keep the night on on d5 to maybe have
the option to play 97 to to cover a 60
just activate the King now for instance
at five you should be F 397 and then
bring the king over yeah it's just a
draft but if I've was was a bit silly me
of course I have night before here but
the problem is that he will try to win
this on time no matter what what the
position is of course is also a dead
draw it needs to capture and then he
wins wins b5 within completely worthless
extra porn and maybe I should have done
this anyway this is already a bit
uncomfortable a bit still should be a
draw but we should yeah it's not I need
to need to find the proper piece
placement here we should deform maybe
this is already already better think the
point is just gone and while it is still
very dry it sounds uncomfortable of
course yeah it's not the nicest opponent
to have